football à présent c'était la reprise ce
week-end en championnat pour la plupart
des clubs du film en excellence mens pas
je verrai ce dimanche contre le pec à
domicile à hong kong s'est terminée par
un spectaculaire 3 but partout je ne
savais jamais encore davantage vainqueur
de la coupe des ivy l'auteur d'une
septième place en championnat lors de la
saison 2015-2016 laisse maupas commence
par un match nul à domicile et ça
continue on était tenu en échec 3 buts
partout par le pecq à l'occasion de la
première journée du championnat
excellence demeure pas un mail et
pourtant trois en seconde période à
s'écrouler en fin de match déçu parce
que ils descendent des péages donc on
s'attendait à voir une grosse équipe
puis finalement je me suis trouvé enfin
on s'est trouvés dessus sur ce match
donc frustré que qu'on n'est pas réussir
à gagner ce match donc après ces
premiers matches on aura d'autres
matches à jouer c'est le physique a pété
les plombs de balle de lucidité et ans
est remonté à 3 parcours pour lancer sa
saison les verts devront s'imposer le
dimanche 18 septembre sur le terrain
douille la saison alors l'équateur
du potentiel et qui dans le groupe c
lors que d'attirer quelque 400 copies
tout est possible et ainsi que
l'excellence et la qualité des équipes
qui sont aussi prouvé les voilà donc que
les rebelles j'espère qu'elle sera le
meilleur sur tous les 21 malades matches
qui restent encore à championnat on
espère monter je l'espère on va prendre
les matches match par match et on verra
comment ça va se passer mais on a un bel
effectif qui fait qu'on pourra jouer la
montée choix à l'issue de cette première
journée nos repas occupe la 7e place du
classement ce championnat excellence à
12 équipes